she's an American actress model and
businesswoman her honest company
business has become a huge success with
a 1 billion dollar valuation
she has an estimated net worth of over
200 million dollars
she's Jessica Alba and here her top 10
rules for success when I was a kid my
parents said anything that you want you
can achieve you just have to work really
really hard for it I spent a lot of time
in my head fantasizing about being a
superhero and about being somebody else
and what would it be like to live
someone else's reality there weren't so
many women that were action stars I
thought that it would be really cool to
be able to kick some butt the resistance
that anybody has whether you're a man or
a woman to your idea should do nothing
but Drive you forward and and force you
to really hone in on your idea and give
you energy and if it actually holds you
back and makes you second-guess yourself
then maybe you shouldn't be doing it um
creating a business is impossible at
times it feels impossible and so you
really have to be I'm just so passionate
about it and you know really don't take
no for an answer
if anything can like deviate you from
your path then maybe it's it's not
necessarily the right one so make sure
it is what you want it to be stay
focused and and allow all that
resistance along the way to really give
you energy and fuel your engine to move
forward I always help you know I think I
do unto others what they what I would
want them to do into me at the end of
the day my parents always taught me that
and so I treat people the way I wanted
to I want to be treated and and that's
kind of the standards that I live by you
know we have direct access to our
customer because I I'm into social media
and I want to hear feedback from
parents how they like our products and
what they would like to change and how
they would like to innovate found on
these products to have like a brand
that's for parents that you know is made
by parents and then we're listening to
parents on how to to change and grow and
evolve I think the thing the big
differentiator with our company versus
the other companies out there is you
know they spend millions and millions of
dollars on product development to make a
product for one cent they want to make
the cheapest product as humanly possible
and they don't really look at the health
ramifications on or the healthiness of
it it's really just how cheap and
high-volume and we're exactly the
opposite and so we spend a lot of money
on product development on high
performance on the best ingredients the
healthiest ingredients but really honing
in on performance I think it's important
for there to be really no bureaucracy
here everyone has a voice I encourage
people to be creative and inspired no
matter what position you're in here
everyone has an equal playing field in
making this company the best company it
can be so whether it's someone in our
warehouse who isn't a fantastic artist
and he brings his art to some of our
customers by spending you know he's
spent 12 hours this one employee of ours
Dylan who's a rock star and he spent 12
hours customizing a box a month for one
of our customers whether he's doing a
dinosaur a robot whatever it is it just
we want to bring delight and happiness
to people outside our customers but also
inside so we do whatever we can we have
karaoke nights
we have what do you what do you think
would be the best thing in the whole
world that you would want this company
to do days which is every day and you
know I'm an actor so I really approach
it from like a more playful creative
kind of mentality and I really want
people to be inspired and have fun and
and I want them to really challenge
themselves to push the limits well I was
twelve so I didn't really have any idea
of anything other than what I was doing
and I you know I just hustled and I
tried to be professional and tried to
learn from my mistakes and just try to
stay two steps ahead of everyone and get
those jobs did you know that at that age
this is what you want to do for the rest
of your life because a lot of people
will get these jobs when they're young
and they think okay this is good for
high school or whatever but when did you
make that decision this is going to be a
life
what did she got dark angel because I
didn't want to be a struggling
professional in anything my parents you
know financially they didn't have a lot
and they struggled a lot and so I just
wanted to make sure that I was going to
be set and I wasn't going to struggle
and when I got dark angel that was like
okay maybe that I can do this for a
living and and maybe it could be a real
career for me being intuitive is
important and then surround yourself
with really smart business people that
can support your weaknesses know what
they are I know I don't know how to
create an e-commerce platform I'm well
aware of that
so I surrounded myself with people who
can and who do do that um and then as
far as mentors go
countless I really I was not shy about
making phone calls to many people I've
been fortunate enough to know people
like Tory Burch and Diane Von
Furstenburg and they you know got lots
of emails and phone calls for me along
the way with tears in my eyes saying I
don't know this is possible why is
everyone telling me
what do I do what does it even mean to
go to to get venture cow
what is venture capital what's a board
like I just didn't know all these
business terms and so they they helped
me understand it I needed people telling
me no I needed people to not get it and
look at me cross-eyed for me to really
figure out exactly what I was gonna do
and how I was going to do it it's
something I had to learn as a woman in
business is a to ask for help
and to not be afraid of criticism um and
and when you don't know what to do to be
okay with not knowing but learning and
also to not be defined by your mistakes
there's challenges there's roadblocks
there's mountains and you just have to
figure it out you just have to be
malleable you have to surround yourself
with really smart people and I didn't
think I was smart for a really long time
cuz if you're smart now yeah I think I'm
um I think I'm um we're we agree you
know I'm not the smartest but but I try
I had this idea on how a family brand
can be built that was honest and
convenient the thing that drove me was
wanting the best and setting the bar
really really high there's always a way
to do it better people looked at me like
I was nuts you wanted to do all of this
like it's too big of an idea they're
like why don't you just do an
endorsement it would just be so much
easier and it was about money for them
and I was like but this isn't about
money for me I needed to do this for my
daughter I need to do this for other
families there was no way that I could
give up until I gave it my all thank you
guys so much for watching I made this
video because Robin Nicole song writer
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of Jessica Alba's top ten
rules meant the most to you you're going
to take some action on leave it in the
comments and I'm going to join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and you'll see you
soon